[Aplausos]
para comenzar quiero compartir con
ustedes una anécdota de mi vida personal
cuando era chica mi mamá nos llevaba a
mi hermano ya mi a la plaza todos los
días a mí me encantaba juntar ramitas
flores piedras que no hubiera visto
antes
un día encontró un trébol de cuatro
hojas me maravillaron sus hojas su
tamaño y salí corriendo a preguntarle a
mi mamá qué era eso
eso me explico y también me dijo que
eran de la buena suerte
me llevo más de 30 años elaborar mi
propia idea sobre esto de los tréboles y
la buena suerte
y esta curiosidad que tenía de manera
chiquita me ha acompañado a lo largo de
toda mi vida y en mi actividad actual me
permite conocer personas y lugares muy
diversos
he escuchado historias de violencia de
exclusión
de falta de oportunidades
he conocido personas de todas las edades
tamaños creencias y me fue preguntando
por qué nos cuesta tanto conectar
porque muchas veces nos tratamos mal
y fui dándome cuenta que nuestras
diferencias se interponen y tenemos una
tan larga lista de estereotipos y
prejuicios en la cabeza que no nos
permiten conectar los estereotipos que
nos llevan a poner a las diferencias
como un problema y a las similitudes
como una virtud
una de esas historias es la de maría
maría tiene 15 años se acercó a mí
después de un taller en un colegio
secundario y me dijo que ella no se
sentía igual que el resto de sus
compañeras que mientras todas ellas
volvían a sus casas a estudiar o salir a
pasear esa debía trabajar su mano había
fallecido y junto a su papá debían
sostener el hogar
pero en la escuela donde marie anne
sufría las diferencias porque sus
compañeras la burlaban le daban apodos
por el barrio en el que vivían por la
ropa que llevaban y por la mochila de
escocia que tenían
maría me pidió una cosa que cuando
hablara que cuando diga charlas dijeras
que los apodos los sobrenombres suenan
duelen en la panza como si tepeji cara y
llegó un momento que no sabe si somos o
lo que dicen de vos
otra de esas historias deja de martín
martínez se acercó a mí después de un
taller que díaz en un trabajo en una
oficina este día mi actividad era sobre
diversidad en las organizaciones y me
pasó lo que me suele pasar adultos y
adultas que me cuestionan porque al
final no se puede hacer ni mucho
que le exigen a los que escuchan que se
la banquen y que parecen inmunes al
sufrimiento que podrían estar generando
sus palabras
martín se acercó y me contó que hace
cinco años que estaba en pareja con otro
chico
[Música]
en su trabajo nadie lo sabía había
escuchado demasiados chistes sobre
o sobre lo que debe hacer un
verdadero hombre y elegía el silencio y
mientras todos sus compañeros llenaban
los escritorios de fotos de sus familias
y compartían anécdotas de ellos él
cazaban para protegerse de esas personas
otra de esas historias es la de cielo
cielo dio su primera charla en la
universidad en una actividad que
generamos con mi equipo de trabajo y se
siega pero eso no le impidió comprender
la magnitud de lo que generaron sus
palabras una mujer fuerte que estudia
trabaja y además hace actividades
solidarias su mensaje es contundente la
discapacidad no la define la definen sus
logros su dedicación sus conocimientos
sin embargo las calles el lugar donde en
donde estudian las negativas a tomar una
entrevista de trabajo cuando se enteran
que ciegan todo eso le recuerda que para
la sociedad esa es su discapacidad
qué tienen en común maría cielo y martín
que han sentido que las personas las
miran pero no las ven
que han creído mucho tiempo que había un
problema en ellos
y que tienen en común con vos las mismas
ganas de pertenecer las mismas ganas de
ser parte de un grupo las mismas ganas
de tener oportunidades las mismas que
tenemos
por eso hoy les traigo una invitación a
que aprendamos a mirar nuestras
diferencias desde otro lugar a que
aprendamos a valorar nuestra diversidad
esta es una foto de cómo nos tratamos es
un trabajo realizado por un organismo
público que nos cuenta que el 74 por
ciento de las personas dijo haber
sufrido una situación de discriminación
antes de los 30 años
las calles las escuelas los trabajos son
los lugares donde más nos discriminamos
usamos el barrio en el que vivimos las
posesiones que tenemos y las nuestros
centímetros en el cuerpo para determinar
el valor de una persona
pero lo más llamativo es que aunque
todos sabemos que este problema existe
un 72% de las personas contó haber
presenciado una situación de
discriminación y no haber hecho nada
si imaginamos que fuéramos 10 personas
es probable que siete de nosotros
hayamos sufrido una situación de
discriminación
pero también es probable que siete de
nosotros hayamos visto sufrir a alguien
y no hayamos hecho nada
[Música]
pero lo que los números no nos dicen es
el costo que tiene la discriminación
para la sociedad para discriminar a una
persona necesitamos deshumanizar la y
reducirla a ese único aspecto de su ser
que yo rechazo
es así que la humanidad como sustantivo
como grupo de personas cada vez es menos
humano como adjetivo como esa cualidad
que usamos cuando una persona le importa
a otra
seguramente te estás preguntando dónde
comienza todo esto y ojalá también te
estés preguntando cómo podríamos hacer
para cambiarlo y esto comienza en ese
primer momento en que salimos o te
encuentro con el otro distinto a mí para
intentar formar un nosotros es en ese
momento que nuestras diferencias se
interponen y es tan grande la lista de
estereotipos que tenemos en la cabeza
que no nos permiten ver a la persona que
tenemos delante en ese momento se nos
abren dos caminos
uno es el cargo de autores llaman de
domesticación donde nos enseñan que son
normales que ser diferentes nos muestran
el menú de etiquetas disponibles
etiquetas que van de la mano con
valoraciones y que van formando parte de
nuestra identidad
y en medida que crecemos lo que pensamos
de los otros se nos vuelve más
importante que nosotros
en este camino vamos a invitar a casa
sobre su amiguito amiguita que es como
nosotros
los niños van a la escuela y reemplaza
los nombres de sus compañeros por
etiquetas es tener el gordo la linda
rapea
y los patios se van llenando de líneas
invisibles que dividen a los que
pertenecen
ya de adolescente como salvo little y un
adulto parado en la puerta nos
recordarán si pertenecemos o no
si tenemos suerte entraremos
en este camino leemos los diarios y no
nos llama la atención un titular que
primero nos cuenta la discapacidad de
una persona y después sus logros
en este camino levantamos muros unos
altos que nos dividen por nuestra
religión por nuestras creencias por
nuestra nacionalidad y la lista es
infinita porque levantamos los muros
para dejar afuera todo el que es
distinto a nosotros con la ilusión de un
mundo de iguales que no existen
pero ghana cuando negamos nuestra
diversidad quién gana cuando para
pertenecer todos tenemos que pensar
igual vivir la vida igual vestirnos
igual
quién gana cuando los patios se
transforman en una pesadilla para niños
y niñas que no aprenden como la mayoría
o que no juegan como la mayoría
quién gana cuando aparece la oportunidad
de comunicarnos globalmente a través de
las redes sociales y las usamos para
odiar nos
este es el camino de la inclusión mágica
frase que usó cuando hablamos de incluir
pero sin tener que hacer ningún esfuerzo
por suerte tenemos otro camino se
acuerdan que les conté que cuando era
chica me dijeron que los tréboles de
cuatro hojas daban suerte bueno de más
grande investigue y me enteré que aparte
de 34 hojas los tréboles pueden tener 8
y 10 hojas es decir todos son tréboles
pero diferentes y este es el otro camino
la revolución del trébol una revolución
donde lo distinto es algo bueno trae
suerte si pudimos hacer esto por un
trébol cuanto más podremos hacer por las
personas es una revolución porque no
tenemos tiempo porque hay un montón de
marías cielos y martínez esperando que
dejemos el enorme grupo de personas que
no se involucran es una revolución que
requiere coraje y hospitalidad coraje
para aceptar mi diversidad primero para
valorarle como un ser único e
irrepetible hospitalidad que traducido
del griego quiere decir amor o bondad
hacia los extraños
no estamos hablando de ser todos amigos
estamos hablando de dar una oportunidad
laboral aunque no creamos en la misma
religión o no compartamos ideas
políticas estamos hablando de cambiar el
algo habrá hecho o que se defienda por
el cómo me sentiría yo en su lugar
hablamos de que las empresas sean
lideradas por personas que no minan sólo
las ganancias económicas sino cuanto han
crecido en inclusión e inequidad
se imaginan cómo sería nuestra sociedad
si lográramos que cada vez más personas
fuera por este camino
pueden visualizar cómo mejoraría
nuestras relaciones
mariah no encontraría utilidad de sus
compañeras sino un refugio en frente a
su realidad
cielo dejaría de ser la silla que da
echarlas para pasar a ser reconocida por
sus logros y por sus conocimientos
martín podría trabajar mejor porque al
igual que hacemos todos podría compartir
otros aspectos de su vida con sus
compañeros
después de muchos años tengo mi propia
definición sobre los tréboles y la buena
suerte y creo que si los tréboles
hablarán nos dirían que llegó la hora de
aceptar que lo normal no existe y que
nuestra buena suerte y nuestra fortaleza
como humanidad están en que aprendamos a
valorar nuestra diversidad
comencemos juntos esta revolución que
poco a poco nos va a ir haciendo más
humanos y que nos va a permitir dejar un
mundo mejor que el que nos encontramos
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]